now a long-standing ban on women
entering football stadiums in Iran is
expected to be lifted on Thursday for a
World Cup qualifier thousands of tickets
allocated for women sold out in minutes
FIFA will be sending a delegation to
Tehran to monitor access to the game
against Cambodia last month you may
remember 29 year old Sahara BRE died
after setting herself on fire she was
protesting after she was arrested for
trying to enter a football match so
let's talk to you football journalist
ashoka Mugisha who is joining us from
Kampala in Uganda on skype nice to have
you with us uh sure
it shouldn't take a woman burning
herself to death for this to happen
clearly the story wouldn't have gotten
as much focus if that hadn't happened
but I guess this does show that there is
some movement in Iran yes absolutely
it's very good news to know that next
week when Iran plays Cambodia in that
FIFA World Cup qualifier that will have
women finally you know in Tehran
watching from the stands and cheering on
though these players of perhaps they've
been watching on the internet or on
television it's a very big step
especially in the Arab world because
it's not be it's not been easy and it
has really hard to take a strong action
from FIFA and pressure groups across the
world to make sure that this happens but
you know it's a reflection also of where
we're going as women in football I
should say for my different aspects
because when you look at FIFA itself the
first ever woman to be a
secretary-general she is mourning and
she is seen up you know so that's
discussed to say the direction with
Recife is very serious about this matter
and to say that look Iran if you don't
let these women watch from the stadium
you could actually be banned from
college occasional coffee so they still
do you think an overriding feeling I
guess in the Arab world you were
referring to expect particularly there
that that women don't want to go to
football or shouldn't be going to
football I mean there was only what was
it three and a half thousand tickets
allocated
yes it's 3,500 that at least have been
confirmed as having gone through female
fun but also there's a feeling that this
number could also rise because the
Federation has and the government of
Iran has said that you will open up more
seats in the stadium and perhaps to
confirm that there'll be more fun but I
must say that when you look at the rest
of the Arab world you have for example
in Africa you have Sudan that is
stuffing a women's national league and
very promising I should say right now
there was one under 20 tournament
ongoing in Morocco that has our Algeria
and Tunisia seeking facts so this is
sort of an encouragement to say that
wearing a hijab is not it's not a bad
thing and that if you want to watch
football you can actually go out there
and and watch really you should not be
limited just because of who you are and
how you were born it's not your fault
that you were born a woman the case of
Sahara code yari the 29 year old who I
said who set herself on fire because she
was arrested for trying to enter a
football match that is a desperately sad
situation isn't it that someone goes to
that length because they were arrested
just trying to watch a game I can't even
begin to imagine the frustration that
she had because as a female journalist I
know that I face other kinds of
opposition I should say in my career
because people don't believe that I can
talk football's the same way that a male
journalist can but some of these things
are changing but when I look at the Iran
situation and what she had to go through
because she has to prove that you know
women can also be fun for football and
and that it took at that of course she
doesn't know the extent with which her
actions help to free up so many other
women in Iran but she she will always be
celebrated as a mother as one who died
for a good cause
even if it's a very bad thing but I'm
sure that when those women go out next
week to support Iran against Cambodia it
will be
a celebration and independence kind of
message that they would send for it for
instance maybe to prefer to say look
here we are we can take selfies in the
stadium and you don't have to disguise
ourselves as men to watch a football
game great stuff Ashok Kumar is joining
us from Kampala thank you appreciate
that